it's time for screen junkies boobie
bytes well when a movie fights everybody
we're about to movie fight and dance
like no one's watching thank you for
tuning in and I gots to ask one question
where my owls at hoot-hoot
what's up hashtag owl nation hashtag
Percival's in the house and yeah for
those of you like was he talking about
yeah I like to call the fans of Hub
movie fights owl nation enjoy we've got
a fun fight plan today and we've got
three awesome combatants to throw down
let's uh let's see who we got
oh this gentleman he writes the honest
trailers
he does the comedies he's an all-around
awesome dude Joe M effing star Joe
what's up buddy I have been looking
forward to this episode of movie fights
since about 15 minutes ago when I
realized I was doing it yes Joe one of
the part of this fight I mean Joe is a
man of many talents including the break
glass in case of emergency talent when
we have someone who cannot make it at
the last moments and Joe I thank you and
I know I know your game I know you come
to play I got this got this come to win
I'm imagining you in a cubicle made of
glass that just waiting for somebody to
break it and release you spends the day
in a very uncomfortable
okay I want to right second up in chair
number two you've seen her all over
twitch you too and she's finally making
her return to movie fights Trisha
Hershberger I'm so excited to be back on
movie fights after all this time it's
great to have you back Trisha and I you
your Flair is off the charts today can
you show further on your stylized
Infinity Gauntlet yes I am look at that
I can I just got this about a month ago
and it's so cool it's kind of the best
thing ever
I mean the best thing ever and it's
super comfortable and ladylike I like
the geek chic where it's just got a
touch of feminine you're crushing it and
you're playing for that you're oh and
you're rocking the Marvel course a
yellow marvel corset on boy something
that I have me with castlecore Satori
because I'm actually if anyone please
tweet me if anyone has found this I'm
looking for like waist belts that our
fandom and phantom theme and I have not
found any online so the best I the
closest I found so far is underbust
corsets but I am on a mission right so
that you can wear like a plain black
dress and then just throw in like a Star
Wars belt or something about fashion
with a belt the viewers of this show
I just learned a waist belt was a thing
it is yeah thought they were just felt
right well uh Trish I wish it worked in
that endeavor and I'd like to introduce
our third contestant she just made an
awesome debut in the debut death match
she's a super funny comedian just one of
the best Julia Prescott yeah have you
here I love that home or napping sure
just your your you teamed up you have a
book that just came out they just came
out sessions related instances I have a
Simpsons podcast with Ali garde scholars
everything's coming up Simpsons on max
fun and then we just co-wrote a book
which if you're gonna write a book may I
recommend co-writing it with somebody
you just write half a book and then you
take a nap but we just came out with
this book it's on triumph books that's
called a hundred things Simpsons fans
shouldn't know one do before they die
and yeah it's out you can read it it's
not in any particular BuzzFeed listicle
order just flip through and have fun
that's so awesome cuz that's a show that
has so much lore and so much to explore
that's very cool it was hard to
determine I mean our publishers wanted
us to cover everything so we have a
chapter called who is Homer and then we
have a chapter about Helens mole man's
real age so it's like okay yeah so you
got the broad you got the deep cuts see
nice Julia thank you for being here and
forward to the fight and deciding the
fight will be myself and the dance on
the damn cat
Oh Dan Moreau I you know what I wasn't
aware of this Dan Moreau our fact
checker but I see her jaws phone case
yes shouldn't doesn't surprise me I just
didn't realize you had is that new for a
few weeks
yeah just like everything's coming out
Milhouse for Dan everything's coming up
G all going out Jaws for me yes nation
where you at Dan good to see you buddy
comedy Alvers shark that's a real movie
isn't it Dan on the facts and the
judging and we also have the voice of
the people she is delightful she is
hilarious welcome Danielle Radford hi I
am the voice of y'all there are lots of
really fun polls if you go on to the
movie fights laugh hashtag those do not
count for the games the one that counts
for this is the poll that is on YouTube
and that will be used as a tiebreaker
but will still be even if it doesn't
wind up having to be something that
counts will still be letting everyone
know how you voted if you are looking
for how that works click in the
description box below or going over to
the chat I'm sure someone has copy paste
and instructions on how to do that um
but also I'll be checking the movie
fights live so if you have any
additional answers and the insights
please send them my way I think I need
sharks now sharks now sharks and owls
you know that this place is gonna be a
whole zoo before we're done Thank You
Danielle and just FYI quick refresher it
is the first player to four points win
so we have three regular round questions
than our two top scores we'll move on to
the speed round and someone can be down
three zip and speed round and make a
furious comeback we've seen some crazy
turns of events so without further ado
what do you say jte let's drop that
package
ladies and gents its main event time
[Music]
Thank You Thor GTA the best package in
the biz alright uh-oh this question
gamers get excited Red Dead Redemption -
everybody's talking about and biggest
weekend gross of any piece of
entertainment in history that's kind of
wild yeah that I'm a little bit
broadsided by that fun fact um so we
asked today who should star in and
direct the Red Dead Redemption movie who
should star in and direct the Red Dead
Redemption movie and we're gonna start
with my man Joestar so uh first of all I
want to say je Washington was gonna be
you today you had a last second audition
and you got it you got make that money I
think so good luck sir and I'm very
excited to fight your answers on movie
fights so this is gonna be a true story
Red Dead Redemption guys I've been
thinking about this a lot we played the
game the first one okay I have not
played the second I can't but I've been
thinking about this question for minutes
and and you could seem like a lifetime
so yeah yeah Red Dead Redemption
open-world game and I think even though
the minke the characters of Red Dead
return like Skyrim where you sort of put
whatever you want into into your into
your character this is this is like a
defined this is like a defined like
written character that has its own arc
you're still you still sort of imprint
yourself on this main character this is
someone that you want to be this someone
you're gonna spend what 366 hours of
game time with so don't you want to be
somebody that on the big screen that
everyone wants to be and that's
America's Sweetheart Jon Hamm oh yeah
as the lead of Thursday preemption no
you're not do we
Jon Hamm he's got range he's got that
that cold fury from Mad Men that cruelty
streak that you need in a Western
revenge tale he's he's done thrillers
he's done comedies the guy has so much
range he could carry a you know a movie
like this a Western can't just be pure
action a western can't just be pure
anger it's got to have those moments of
levity it's got to have those moments of
just pure cool Jon Hamm can deliver
those my director sometimes you don't
want to get super creative in Hollywood
sometimes you just want sometimes you
just want to be like you know what yeah
that guy James Mangold he made Logan he
made 310 days a month that guy made
Logan have him dude non-marine Logan
people will love that pairing with Jon
Hamm dream team we got Joe's combo Joe I
love they pronounced Skyrim like a
spider-man
minion it's from Louisville where you
don't write any syllables in Louisville
so I say screw em I like a lot all right
thank you Joe star Trisha what do you
got okay so I went with Josh Brolin as
my leading lit man for Red Dead
Redemption I was just playing the second
one this morning it's very good if
anyone hasn't had a chance to play it
yet I think Josh Brolin would be an
excellent choice as john marston which
is the protagonist from the first Red
Dead Redemption but let's set it during
the time of of his in his later life so
Josh Brolin then would be
age-appropriate if we're looking at it
that way I think that we have seen him
do incredible things in no country for
old men we've seen him as dan white and
milk we have seen him be that villain so
we know that he can be that Western
gangster type he's got that grit he's
got that the villainous streak I mean
Santos Dan White we've seen him as the
villain in American Gangster Planet
Terror like tons and tons of those he
was in a movie called Gangster Squad if
anyone has doubts about Josh Brolin's
ability to be the heart Yanks
is there and then I would have it
directed by James mangled as well yeah
solid cop thank you Joe and I would say
again not only 3:10 to Yuma where we've
seen that he can do Western as a genre
so he could give life and love to this
world but also looking at Logan we've
got we've got the gritty action with a
loveable dark hero and that's really
what we're getting in Red Dead
Redemption so I think if you--if 3:10 to
Yuma and Logan had a baby I think it
would make a very nice source accurate
depiction of what a Red Dead Redemption
movie would be right on ok Thank You
Tricia Julia Prescott yes I'm here to be
here oh no why would you cuz you didn't
do it for anyone else sorry right on I'm
starting to I'm still learning in real
time how to do this
oh hell yeah here's my answer go to the
fire yeah I believe that Red Dead
Redemption which I will admit is a piece
of culture that I have not been exposed
to at all in any form besides hearing
about it for today but that's okay
because I did some research and I found
out that it was a Western and I want to
say that I want to do a two-hander a
writer-director star maybe a three
hinder and my answer is Josh GAD I
believe the Josh GAD should write into
this film and star in it because let's
talk about what happens when westerns
come out and they're just beige right or
when movies come out and they're just
beige they don't have anything that pops
with them I'm gonna pull a reference
that you're not going to expect Bohemian
Rhapsody is coming out this weekend
and the reviews have not been good
because it's just been beige it's been
very safe and it is a very formulaic
biopic of Queen which is not what they
deserved it is Irv Moore and I believe
the same thing with a Western you know
so I'm just gonna go in that direction
because I don't know read that
Redemption I believe that it should be
you know something that kind of disrupts
what the genre is
should be something that you know
subverts what we expect for it I believe
that josh brolin and james mangold are
very good choices but i feel like there
are a little bit more on the Bayshore
side I don't know if you've been
following Josh Brolin's Instagram but I
would rather pay full admission Arclight
prices to just watch a stream of his
Instagram goofing off then I'm starring
in another Western and we all want to
see him shirtless but come on we could
also see that on his Instagram I believe
that Josh GAD is the correct choice for
this because it is completely against
time even though as an actor he's been
trying to go into the more serious roles
and you know we all saw him we all saw
him and the orient-express
right wasn't that murdering yeah that
was the best movie of last year I think
and I want him to branch out from there
the last time that he had producing and
writing credit on something was the
comedians and I believe that there needs
to be a palate cleanser in the pop
culture for Josh Gannon I also think
that it is such a bizarre choice that
would defy everyone's expectations that
there would be think pieces written
about it
for I'm gonna say at the very least five
years after its release and that is my
answer
Wow that Canadians with Billy Crystal
right paper it should have succeeded for
seven seasons in a movie there you go
fight it out y'all
so talk about the age appropriateness of
a Josh Brolin versus I feel like that
was a jab at the eternal Fountain of
Youth that is John Hamm and I don't
think you need to worry about age of
appropriateness for a Western because
everyone who's ever started a Western
and I include the young guns in this
looks like they're made out of a piece
of old leather there's just something
about shooting in the desert that just
automatically does that they've been
through something tough but I want to
ask you if you are basing your casting
of Jon Hamm on the character of John
Marston the former outlaw from the first
Red Dead Redemption he's about 25 in
that game let me tell you something
about accurate facts from a video game
movie I don't want them
anytime we try to make a video game
movie where we're like here's this thing
from the game and here's this thing from
the game and here's this thing with the
game we come up with a bad movie
yeah and further with with adventure
games like this it's the same reason why
I don't want an uncharted game where
you've already gotten a complete story
in there and if I already played it I
already experienced it I don't
necessarily need to see the whole thing
give me something that that feels Red
Dead Redemption II but it's new and give
it to me with Jon Hamm and the absolute
safest pick for director for this shame
is mangled you know I'm having a lot of
hard times coming up with an argument
against Josh GAD thank you John is the
idea that everyone's seen too much beige
and any of the other choices that we had
mentioned in our arguing would be too
safe of picks for this movie to that I
would say we have yet to see a video
game movie that's done right that's done
well that's been a big success so the
studios are still very very hesitant to
fund video game movies because we
haven't seen them work out great so I
think we need a slam-dunk on this one
it's too early to take a chance in the
video game movie genre I disagree I
don't think that it's too early I think
that like what I mean well let's think
about it in the broad strokes if it why
haven't the do game movie how why isn't
it work because I do believe that they
have been playing it a little too safe
with like the direct conversion of final
fantasy and then final fantasy the movie
or whatever I think that it needs to be
something that is like a big swing and I
also would say I know that it sounds
like I'm just saying the funny answer
which I am because I'm a comedian it is
but I'm also thinking that you know
what's better to witness a hero's
journey of a soft soft Josh GAD be put
through that machine of the West and
become say a John Hammond to avenge
turns him into chewing leather I like it
it's just that's not what red dead
redemption is red dead redemption in
both the first and the second game we're
looking at a weathered criminal that has
been a gangster for quite some time
I understand sorry John Hamm can you
know definitely definitely pull off you
know he's the villain and and kimmy
schmitt he's a very dangerous individual
in that show if you haven't seen it and
here's a cake a very funny show he's
still a funny character absolutely and a
Western should have a little bit of
levity and here's something that I can't
stop thinking about with Jon Hamm who's
the king of the Western Clint Eastwood
and who made his film debut with Clint
Eastwood Jon Hamm in 2000 space cowboys
together just talking about the ins and
outs of the Western that guy's been
inside Clint Eastwood's head and that's
gonna make him fantastic lead for a Red
Devil we've seen Jon Hamm be serious in
a movie or is he still our comedy guy
2010 called stolen which is a which is a
pretty good heist movie sequel to taken
and again you know you you pair the safe
choice which I really think is ham
people want to see him succeed people
people always root for this guy so why
not give them the the most obvious this
is this is the obvious choice and
sometimes the obvious choice is just the
good one putting the Louvin guy with the
man baby i would not be unhappy which on
him on my screen but i will say that you
are never going to have like the fans
are going to find ways to be you know
betrayed by whatever big screen
adaptation of their favorite thing
you're never going to win with it so you
might as well go big or go home
that's not true that you're never gonna
win with it there is not a more
passionate crowd out there than the
fandom audience than the nerd audience
and when something great question is
celebrated when something's done right
let's move to our final thoughts
Joe why don't you go ahead and sum it up
and then we'll go around the horn I
think there is something to the obvious
choice that sometimes doesn't seem like
the sexiest but it's the right choice
and then sometimes in the case of Jon
Hamm the obvious choice is also a very
sexy choice so boom there you go I
honestly think this is a guy who's
waiting for his his his leading man
moment I think that that announcement on
line where it's Jon Hamm tap to lead the
Red Dead redhead movie we break the
internet I would get people sort of
super pumped and excited and look if you
direct if you choose anyone to direct
but James Mangold the Internet
those same passionate of fans will be
like why is it this film being directed
commanded directed Logan this is this is
absurd so go it go with just the really
really clear obvious pick ham mangled
for 2018 thank you sir Trisha Han Gold
thoughts neither Jon Hamm nor Josh GAD
really hit the tone of what Red Dead
Redemption is and neither of them are
the correct type for our protagonist Jon
Hamm like it or not now we've seen him
be funny so many times he's one of those
actors that every time you see him on
screen
he's Jon Hamm as that role you can't be
taken into that movie by him or it's
much harder now than it used to be for
sure he's just a funny guy and the same
thing with Josh GAD he's the total wrong
tone Josh Ganz the total wrong tone for
Red Dead Redemption movie and yeah you
do we really want to see Olaf as a
Western gang member or Lefou I don't
think that's where we need to go for Red
Dead Redemption that being said we have
seen Josh Brolin be an amazing villain
who is still a villain that we like and
that we side with look at Santos like
that's what we need if we're gonna go
with John Marston or Arthur Morgan he
could do either of those roles our two
Red Dead Redemption protagonists
beautifully and of course James Mangold
is the perfect choice to direct this
film Thank You Tricia Julia alright Josh
Brolin just because he could
not mean that he should is is this going
to be just another bullet point on his
extremely long IMDB page I just feel
like it's not going to be something that
he cares about but if you get a passion
project from Josh GAD he's premier he
has been working and slaving over it
ignoring his young children to tweak and
polish this is his entry into that
illustrious domain of comedy actors that
have gone serious we know how much Jim
Carrey wanted it with the majestic and
then he righted the wrong with man in
the [ __ ] moon can I curse I'm so
sorry and I just feel like we're gonna
watch a movie that's going to give a
[ __ ] and then come Oscar season we're
gonna go you know what it was a big risk
but I'm so happy I was here for the ride
because otherwise Red Dead Redemption
the movie would be [ __ ] forgotten left
to be a five dollar target DVD bargain
bin along with [ __ ] Wow
you know we will be wound up with Josh
GAD lifting Oscar gold Thank You Julia
for that impression answer
time time Dan Morelle want to put the
should we put the brakes on the f-bomb
minutes that this videos monetized was
nice but I'm sorry that's okay that's
okay it's the GATT in me when you start
talking guy and your language gets bad
[Applause]
factually yes what few things a little
bit more detail on that record Red Dead
Redemption to have a seven hundred
twenty five million dollar opening
weekend whoa that eclipsed the previous
record-holder which was infinity war
when it came out of that six hundred
forty five forty million dollar opening
weekend the overall record holder was
grand theft auto 5 that made a billion
dollars over the same amount of time
again rise at Tuesday again with rock
star but it came out on a Tuesday so the
weekend wasn't so it's the opening
weekend record that read Deborah to old
Scaccia Josh GAD was credited as a
producer on the comedian's but not a
writer only is it an EP on that film jon
Hamm's role in space cowboys it was his
future debut he was young pilot number
two directed by Clint Eastwood and on
the subject of John Marsten's age he was
38 in the first Red Dead Redemption game
and he is 26 there's a new one which
takes place Josh GAD can play both of
those ages for ya Dan I thank you sir
okay so yeah this was this is a fun
battle this is a fun question to answer
and I Julia I mean there's I love your
passion I feel like there's just a
little too much against GAD he hasn't
played this type of character before it
might not be the quite the fan service
and setting the stage for his
[ __ ] and the fact that I'm Red Dead and
the fact that has Hugh said this would
be his directing debut be here as a
director yes this is the right vehicle
maybe they should stand is laying a
little bit more I don't want to I don't
want to cut his dreams or anything but
so for me it came down to Joe and Trish
and I think Trisha just had more of a
point-by-point breakdown of Roland's
career and I mean as much as fun as I
love the notion of the news of Jon Hamm
being in cast and Red Dead breaking the
Internet
I think Trish had the more complete
answer so I'm going Trisha with Josh
Brolin and James mangled Dan yeah I felt
like there were two components to this
answer that you had to sell equally
because right about not just your actor
and director if you lean too far to one
of the other I think that might not have
helped you very much and I thought the
most well-balanced argument as far as
both for and against was Trish's
argument I felt like Jo got a little too
hung up on Jon Hamm Josh GAD I just
wasn't working for me so I gotta go
alright Trisha takes the point Danielle
and what the internet let me say I'm
with 41% josh brolin james mangold 39%
jon hamm james mangold with 18% you know
what respectable you got that's a strong
edge it's a strong 18 Danielle what else
did you see that caught your fancy oh
well this is a really good one so at Jay
Peck 1098 on Twitter said Red Dead
Redemption Bradley Cooper as john
marston and ridley scott as the director
it will be a horror movie at that point
if he does the Jackson main voice
alright
he just loses the voice for 20 minutes
anyway or shark memes we have gotten so
many sharks great
go go go find the sharks a lot of people
apologizing for never seeing jaws and
they were apologizing directly to Dan
accept your apology only if you go watch
us jaws yeah yeah that's how you get
apology yep don't apologize
great Dan you are III mean for me you
are the preeminent jaws fan I'm one
there are many more oh I invited Andy I
love that movie very great right on sir
alright so after one question it is
Trisha won Julia and Joe nil looking to
get on the board and let's move on to
question number two I Tiffany hashes new
movie nobody's fool comes out this
weekend marking her fourth big screen
movie this year and the third in just
the last six months she is on a roll and
ya blew up after girls trip and killing
it so we asked you to pick one actor
that you would choose to star in every
movie for an entire year okay if you
have to see one actor I'm here in every
moment here
that's like lots of movies yeah who
would it be and this is question number
2 so we're gonna start with player
number 2
Trish what a hard question first of all
but I'm pretty confident in my answer
I chose Donald Glover as the actor that
I would like to start in every movie for
an entire year because everything he
touches turns to gold
this man has maybe sold his soul to the
devil I don't know but somehow he is an
amazing actor comedian singer writer
producer director rapper DJ he's good at
everything he does he's won an Emmy
everybody loves him he's one of the most
likable actors right now so I feel like
he would keep the box-office thriving
unlike maybe some other stars who we
might get sick of after the first
quarter of the year and then if
movie industry died out where would we
all be it'd be the most devastating
thing but we've seen him do all
different types of rain so much
diversity that I think that we would
have a good chance of getting quite a
few hits out of that year instead of
just getting bored all right Trish on
the board with Donald Glover Julia my
pick is Tilda Swinton because I feel
like her versatility as an actor is you
know it really knows no bounds I mean
there's so many articles on the internet
that say that she is an alien from
another planet and she has not disputed
it and I feel like she is the kind of
actor what you need for this situation
is I think that it needs to be like sort
of hiding in plain sight because I think
we're all going to start to deteriorate
as a race watching movies that are all
featuring one person I think that we're
all going to get fatigued no matter who
they are and let's be real Donald Glover
needs to have a starring bill and every
single thing that he touches but Tilda
Swinton on the other hand she can play a
fixture in the background of the new
Harry Potter movie that has no lines and
no name and is just in the background of
every shot and and she would be fine
with that and nobody would be surprised
to hear that Tilda Swinton was wallpaper
for two and a half hours and I think
that's what we need for this all right
Thank You Julia comedy with Tilda
Swinton Joe do you ever answer certain
done by any chance I do what's mine oh
you were formerly Jays answer it is
samuel l.jackson so how are you doing
samuel l.jackson
only obvious choice for this because the
Donald Glover is great he's the hot new
thing and and Tilda Swinton is this
incredible character actor but sometimes
you just you just want to know exactly
what you're getting you just want some
good security and that's samuel
l.jackson just being samuel l.jackson
over and over and over and over and over
and over and over and over and over
again this question was inspired by
Tiffany Haddish Samuel Jackson's pretty
much in the same amount of movies and if
that's not factually true it's it's
emotionally true it has never bothered
me once to see Samuel Jackson appear on
screen
whether it's across from Ryan Reynolds
or or it's across from John Travolta or
it's across from Eddie Murphy and just
yell something in a samuel l.jackson
kind of way we can watch it over and
over and over again it's the most
amazing kind of junk food just watching
samuel l.jackson yell whether he's
getting eaten by a shark more or just
warning people that they need to hold
their butts he's asking what's in your
wallet you never ever get tired of the
man so that that's my answer
Samuel Jackson he operates on his own
scale of actor rating thank you sir all
right fight it out y'all all right who
wants to go first I'll jump in there yes
samuel l.jackson deserves to start
[Music]
all right Jojo here's now you see you
filibuster you said that you just love
hearing Samuel Jackson yell things over
and over and over and that makes a good
movie America does I think you also
argued against yourself when you said
that we have seen him do that time and
time again
here's we've gotten the same thing over
and over and over
do we want another year of that Jackson
movie Nova Samuel Oh Jackson has never
been bad in a movie and the problem with
Donald Glover you know Gould
everything's gonna be gold everything he
touches turns to gold are you familiar
with the tale of King Midas Trisha gold
gold loses value she has much less
precious dependable stone who's always
gonna be there who's always gonna
deliver who's always a solid I would
argue that that you enjoying him is one
man's opinion I think what's really
going on is that nobody knows how to
tell him no I think everybody's really
just scared of him and so he's able to
just as you did you see it free and
Kingsman yeah do you see him try that
weird accent for the first time in his
life and it was great it was ill-advised
oh and you know it but you know what
everyone came out of that movie going
what was samuel l.jackson doing and they
shook their hands and they're in their
hands
you came and saw another sip
but did that but did that deter you from
wanting to see samuel l.jackson again in
the future but in every movie for an
entire year snakes on a plane like a you
terrorist black snake mom like I could
just go on just say that Samuel Jackson
is like a Louie CK come back it's not
something that we asked her prepared for
first it led to everyone's favorite line
of that year and now it has been
immortalized as everyone's favorite TV
edit of all time accurate sorry to talk
over you no no no that's what movie
fights is about that's what they love
they love us all just yelling and
shouting over each other I think Donald
Glover is incredibly talented but that's
he's he's a he's a he's a sexy new toy
and samuel l jackson is the teddy bear
you've had since you were a kid you're
always going to go back to that teddy
bear till tell us witness is a great
performer but eventually starring or
heavily starring Tilda Swinton is gonna
is it I think it's gonna start to bore
me to be coming back joke that's on my
point she will not be starring in it
because she is the actors actor like
this girl should do whatever the hell
she wants she can do comedy she can do
drama she can play an alien from space
she can also play it advise other races
that are not her own time for guess so
anyway I think that she would be we
would never get fatigued by Tilda
Swinton and I want to bring this other
point to the court of today
according to her IMDB page she's won one
Oscar I have a phone because nobody gave
me a pen
but she she is not one to and I believe
a second one I also love tell us Winton
I think she's an amazing actress however
I think you argued 100% against yourself
because the question is what actor would
you like to see star in every film for a
year and you said that she wouldn't be
starring she would be great as a
background wallpaper role which I agree
she's a fantastic supporting character
and I would be down to see her be a
supporting character in every movie for
every year the actors are charming I
believe that everybody on the screen is
a star no small parts there are no small
parts only small till does she only be a
background no it should be arranged
she'd be arranged give us something new
every time I know that her choices are
much her choices are so large and so
incredible but I think starring in every
film for a year we would get sick of
that really quick million perhaps Trish
go ahead and roll this in your final
thoughts please okay I'm gonna roll this
into my final thoughts to say that if we
want to see a diverse range of movies
over an entire year we want to see
comedies we want to see romance we want
to see gritty crime dramas we want to
see horror Donald Glover can do all of
that so every time every movie genre
will be successfully satisfied over that
year he's also young enough that he can
play a wide variety of Ages and it's a
it's high time that we get some more
diversity in Hollywood so if every movie
was starring Donald Glover for the
entire year we would feed those urges
whereas I think that Tilda Swinton takes
too large of choices she's a little bit
too out there to be the starring role in
every single film for a year and Samuel
Jackson we've seen it we've seen it time
and time again he does the same thing
all the time and I think audiences will
get bored all right Thank You Trish
Julia okay so I think I've said enough
about Samuel Jackson so I'm just going
to address Donald Glover if you read The
New Yorker profile and Donald Glover
that came out about I want to say like
three or four months ago you can fact
check me on that but in that article one
of the larger themes was that he's great
a tiffany is motivated by being bored
easily so that he even said within that
article that he wasn't sure how long he
was going to be doing it lanta he was
only going to do it as long as it was
fun he was talking about already
quitting the music game and even though
he got cast in Star Wars you know he had
contemplated not doing big movies like
that I think that over the span of a
year Dumbo clever will get bored and
whatever contract this magical movie
realm has for him he's going to get out
of it because also the one thing that
Donald Glover does above all else is he
does what he does he does not bow to
anybody and I think that it's going to
be unsustainable and then Tilda Swinton
is going to be the best all right Thank
You Julia Joe first I did want to give a
shout out to Trisha for giving the this
question the added depth of the industry
tanking if if this person samuel
l.jackson has sort of this leading man's
curse where it's like he had there's
that there's that knock against samuel
l.jackson where it's like it's the same
thing in and out and in and out we
always know what to expect and yet if
you look at his range Pulp Fiction -
unbreakable - even like a funny action
comedy like hit man's bodyguard yes it's
samuel l.jackson but it's always Samuel
Jackson taking you in a slightly
different direction I think he is this
wonderful balance of movie star and
character actor that not a lot of actors
are able to hit there's that charisma
there that can drive a movie and open a
movie but there's also that that
character actor side of him that were
the really kind of cool and interesting
and different choices keep coming from
where people can sit back and say you
know what I didn't expect a weird creepy
guy in the wheelchair opposite Bruce
Willis from Samuel Jackson I didn't
expect that from him I didn't expect you
know for better or worse weird Lisp a
guy that loves McDonald's from Samuel
Jackson you know they're not necessarily
always going to be good but I'm always
interested in what the guy is going to
bring to the table
whereas you know Donald Glover a
talented guy and he's sort of the you
know he's super hot right now Atlanta's
great he's a strong performer in it but
you know in terms of in terms of movies
solo was a really good Billy Dee
impression but it didn't give me any
sense of like what Donald Glover can
really bring to the table as a leading
man in feature film after feature film
and I think Tilda Swinton is the Bjork
of Hollywood and I mean that in the best
possible way something you're voting for
me you've already closed Prescott but I
think she's she's she's so outlandish
that she can't quite hit that that
perfect balance at Samuel Jackson can
hit of sort of like weird interesting
unique choices and just straightforward
I'm going to get out there and put on
the movie star face and deliver the
lines and open a movie
thank you Joe star boom that is the end
of round number two Admiral would you
kindly favour us with some facts and
then take us into your decision on this
question sure the Joe Haddad said that
it's it feels like Samuel Jackson
appears in the same number of movies
every year that Tiffany Haddish does so
I went into the very limited data on
Tiffany Haddish really this this year
2018 was her first full year after her
breakout once was her samuel l.jackson
year going as far as this year Samuel
Jackson will appear in four films this
year but only starred one of them hasn't
come out yet he's had cameos and voice
voice appearances and other films
Tiffany Haddish also in four films this
year but three starring roles and a
supporting role she has four in line for
next year Samuel Jackson has five in
production for next year so their
numbers are roughly equivalent but I
think that the edge of like who's been
more upfront at least this year has been
Tiffany Haddish
but number wise it's it's it's very
equal so I'll call that I'll call it a
draw on the fashion for that
and yeah as far as as far as that goes
that's all I've got factually thank you
as far as my pic I thought this was very
good debate I think that Tilda Swinton
for my pick for my money was the right
pick but I think Jo ended up making my
favorite argument and so I would go with
Jo and Samuel Jett Jackson his closing
the idea that people sort of paint him
into a corner but he has had a lot of
roles where people say I did not expect
that from him his variability that won
me over and I think that Tricia actually
deemed Julia pretty well on the fact
that it does say star and and not in the
background of or just somewhere in and
that for me was a pretty critical hit as
far as tildes Rowling's to the films I
said Jo argued the question better so I
just thought we were having fun Dan and
you know they'll make and eventually the
Harry Potter movie starring piece of
furniture people to go to Swit part of
the fun is is taking this yeah just like
getting down business really yeah so
that is a great point Dan thinking about
the question because the question does
say star so how many stars does a film
have how many cuz that's what that's
kind of where I'm at you know
can someone be a co-star there's still a
star can someone up here it so what if
they just play to a star yeah what if
they just play it well the swinton is
perfect to do so you mentioned her
versatility you mentioned all the roles
that she played so that that your
arguments right there yeah Trisha I
don't feel like we painted enough of a
versatile picture of Donald Glover I
mean he does a lot like he's a multi -
and he just so many mediums he's amazing
man it but it came down to Joe and Julia
for me and Joe they didn't get hard you
came back real good at the end there
though you really sold it you know what
I feel like the the audience needs to
decide
I'm gonna go I'm gonna go tilde on this
one because I don't think there there's
a hard-and-fast star I think they're
gonna be many stars someone can be a
smaller role but it can be on the list
of starring yes Lance Lang yes yes great
shadow bye hey Julia Danielle take us
there all right with 57% of the vote
samuel l.jackson percent of the vote
goes to donald glover till they get 17
so CJ 182 on Twitter said offered
Bradley Cooper saying God has so much
ranging a new comedy Dan drama action
rom-com and voice-over talent also quite
a few people thought that Julia was
talking about Danny Glover very
different very different I hear that
argument ones in the very twilight of
his career you know I bet Tilda Swinton
could play an owl but when you were
talking about Donald Glover and made me
think from the same show Atlanta black
eats Stanfield he is like has such a I
think he's building a great body of work
I think he can do a lot of different
things in movies so you notice and you
now do al gestures without realizing it
yeah it's part of me I will say one
thing about Tilda Swinton's versatility
yes guess how old Tilda Swinton is I
wouldn't even begin to know she's 58
years old no yes
oh my gosh let's move on around
today we are standing with a score of
Joe one Trisha one Julia looking to get
on the board okay
question three supporting weaver
recently praise Neill Blomkamp's
cancelled alien sequel what abandoned or
canceled film project should have been
made
what abandoned or canceled film project
should have been made it's question
number three so we start with player
number three Julia I'm happy to say that
my answer for this question is 82 if
anyone has ever been on the et ride at
any of the universals in Hollywood or
Orlando then you have been treated to
what would have been a celebration of
the journey that we work didn't go on
were 82 as an audience we would go to e
t--'s Planet Lewis understand who
Botanica is which is his mentor Yoda
like mentor the second half of the et
ride is just a woo it is an acid trip
into the depths of Steven Spielberg's
daddy issues millions that look
whimsical and accoutrement that was
bought at Spencer's gifts in 1997 but
it's a journey that I want to go on and
I want to see what modern technology
would do with it today alright thank you
et tu nocturnal feeders Joe oh do you
want to argue Nightmare Before Christmas
- yes that's correct
guys in the pantheon of you know the
history of failed legendary projects I
think Nightmare Before Christmas - is
definitely absolutely the one that
should have been made look Nightmare
Before Christmas didn't just launch a
popular genre it didn't just launch a
popular soundtrack it launched a popular
lifestyle people have defined their
lives around Nightmare Before Christmas
it launched a very popular mall store
chain I think you could
and more it also launched Burton and and
the creative team around that film in in
an even bigger way than even say
Beetlejuice and Edward Scissorhands had
at that point I think Burton's
attempts to return to the medium have
been less than stellar
I think Nightmare Before Christmas still
sits atop of the stop motion of the
stop-motion world and I think there is
enough space there to really knock out
some really cool new songs and a really
cool fun new story and really those are
second and third two just atmosphere and
fantastic visuals and I think there's
enough there that you could have
returned to Nightmare Before Christmas
too and really just kind of like soaked
it for a little more money and sold
another really really great soundtrack
nightmare for Christmas right now shout
out to Hot Topic Tricia what do you got
I am going to go with at the mountains
of madness the sci-fi horror novel from
HP Lovecraft the Guillermo del Toro has
been dying to do for years this is a
passion project of his and I think it's
pretty easy to see how gamers el Toro
could do a Lovecraft story and really
bring it to life I mean monsters
alternate reality this story that goes
without the mountains of madness is an
expedition to Antarctica goes wrong and
they discover a secret society that's
never been touched with alien life-forms
and people go crazy and it's very
Lovecraftian in all the best ways but
del Toro's passion for this is one of
the reasons why I think we need to see
this mate not only is the story amazing
and Lovecraft is very in right now I
don't know that it was ever out but it's
definitely in right now
del Toro wrote the script in O six he
wrote it as an r-rated nasty like Rioja
and we've seen the success of things
like Deadpool and so just really r-rated
commercial successes when the only
reason it was shot down by Studios
before was because they were afraid to
go without our rating it is now the time
people who have seen the script have
jumped on board big people including
James Cameron Tom Cruise both gave their
support morally and financially that
they wanted to see this made
I mean let's just take a look at Pan's
Labyrinth take a look at how abou this
is the perfect story to be told by del
Toro and I cannot believe this movie has
not been made after all these years okay
fight it out y'all something to be said
for you know beyond if someone has a
passion for it sometimes an artist has a
need to return to something
I think Tim Burton has fallen a bunch
over the last couple years with his
wonderland movies you know were rough
rough rough and sometimes you really
just need to pull back and return to
your claymation dead trees roots and go
back and play in in in a you know in a
yard that you're super familiar with
that you're super comfortable in so that
you can you know thrive a little bit you
know it's which is not the most
necessarily exciting answer in the world
but I think it's a valid one you know
the Cthulhu thing that you know the hard
our cosmic are do we really want a new
event horizon you guys let's leave the
cosmic horror genre of event horizon
takes place in Antarctica well sure you
know you call it Antarctica I call it
the cold dead of space both of them cold
a lot of people basically the same movie
dr. Graham probably be in both of them
Joe I have some questions for you yeah
let's let's talk about it okay so
Nightmare Before Christmas - we all know
the drama and falling out between Tim
Burton and Disney as far as I know
diddly still owns the rights to
Nightmare Before Christmas so if they
were to make a sequel it probably
wouldn't be Tim Burton he would not I I
would I understand raise a counterpoint
yeah sure I believe the Tim Burton is
releasing a Dumbo movie in the
not-too-distant future so I don't
understand what in the law so relation
is and how they would not get along for
a Nightmare Before Christmas - I have
direct Nightmare Before Christmas it was
his idea so let us all remember that
yeah yeah yeah well I I don't
who has the rights to that's still I
just know it was a messy falling-out and
so it might be tough to get that back
with danny elfman be involved again and
historically in Disney sequels if you've
ever seen
Aladdin to any of the other Disney
sequels they're not really that great on
story
what would the story be jack has learned
his lesson I mean at this time is Santa
learning to be scary where are we going
with this the interesting thing about
life is you don't just want learn one
lesson and then you're a fully formed
adult or a fully formed skeleton can
learn and in tandem to that there's a
whole bunch of doors with different
holiday shapes on them that you can
learn those lessons from people have
been saying for years what are behind
the other doors let's find out hello
Julia I haven't heard as much about et -
yeah I would like to talk about et - I
want to say that et - is the best choice
in this category because that script is
a locked and loaded baby he wanted to do
it almost immediately after et but then
you know he got swept up in other
projects and they just couldn't I think
that the universal ride wasn't hitting
the right audiences that they liked and
so he then decided to go into more
serious war war movies and I would also
say that 82 would be great because I
feel like with stranger things emulating
Amblin type tones and a lot of those
others sort of like 80s nostalgia
throwback TV shows and movies that it is
the primetime for et to take center
stage again and you know teach us all
how to love again and teach us all you
know that especially in the current
political arena you know the other night
sort of theme with et being an alien I
believe that this could be the correct
allegory for the correct time for racial
and justice okay I have something to say
about 82 nocturnal fears and maybe my
facts are way off base so I'm interested
to hear what Dan has to say but I
thought that nocturnal fears was like a
nine-page treatment written by Melissa
Mathison after something must have gone
very bad in her life because the entire
second act is pretty much like kiddie
torture porn where they go into the
woods because they think et is returning
and instead they find these horrible
carnivorous like evil aliens
that they're then tortured to and true
Barrymore's character screaming for her
mommy I'm like it's like this really
horrific thing so when your arguments
like teaching kids to love again through
the power of EC that's not what
nocturnal fears is by any means if
that's the movie you're talking about
that was cancelled it should be made I
mean that is that is true what you just
said but you know in the industry as we
all know several polishes and passes can
be made to a treatment to turn it into a
script and so I think that they're going
to bring it to the room and try to you
know incorporate some of the core themes
from the original et into it to kind of
shape into something they wanted it to
be a little bit edgier than the original
et which I believe that in this I mean
again stranger things was like the
edgiest of that kind of Amblin type of
tone isn't your final thoughts Julia
okay great so I want to say that
Deadpool Trish you made the comment
about Deadpool being an example of
horror and its popularity Deadpool is
not a real horror movie it is superhero
snark with funny Gore which I believe
undercuts any sort of horror elements
that it may have while I agree that
Nightmare Before Christmas
2 is something that the people want and
I see them at Disneyland every day not
every day but you know what I mean like
you know just eager and hungry for it I
believe that it could be something that
you know I don't think that you can go
home again with Nightmare Before
Christmas - I think that no matter what
they do it's going to be a
disappointment and the only way that
they would be able to make it not a
disappointment is if they say didn't
have Jack Skellington be the main
character that instead it was another
character sort of going through that
hero's journey again and maybe with
another holiday but we never know and
then I think also that a whole new album
of songs is probably unlikely because as
we saw with Mamma Mia - they didn't even
bother to
paradox didn't even bother to do new
songs they just treated the first ones
which they knew is what we wanted and I
believe that the creators of neighbor
for Christmas - whoever they may be Tim
Burton or not you know I think that it
would be a similar situation I also
think that nerman for Christmas was made
at a time in Tim Burton's career where
he was a little bit thirstier and I
believe that those days have long since
passed and I think the last time that we
saw just a little bit of that thirst was
with Frankenweenie and if I do say so I
think that a lot of that was due to the
screenwriters who also co-wrote Ed Wood
which is the best Tim Burton movie of
all time all right Thank You Julia
background a joke you know I agree that
I think Tim Burton's cred has had took
off a lot because of the team he
surrounded himself with so the team that
wrote Beetlejuice the team that wrote Ed
Wood and I think but I think that's
another reason why you return to
something like Nightmare Before
Christmas - and actually give those
people their there they're just returned
to the to the project you know I feel
like you could show the original
nightmare to fans now and the fact that
Tim Burton doesn't appear in the
directed by like blows people's minds
that he's so like solidly connected to
that so this it's also sort of another
chance to be like you know this was this
is elfin this is so there's like this
huge team behind this thing that really
made it work I think Danny Elfman has
grown so much since then as a musician
as a composer that I think he could
actually do some really really
incredible stuff for this musical and
whether you kept it Jack Skellington or
whether you made it the next generation
and if Jack Skellington and he goes to
st. Patrick's Day land or you know
wherever is that you go I think there's
a fun story that you can mine in this
world I think as long as you keep it
bleak and you keep it dark and you keep
that fun spirit and don't dignify it too
much and lose that sort of twisted miss
that made it so attractive to begin with
I think you have a really good movie
I think the loo projects don't get made
because Cthulhu projects just don't work
at some point in development someone
points at them and says I don't what
what are we doing what are we really
deep ones and the squid man and guys
what is this and then it just siding
goes on the backburner I think that
there's a reason why they stay in the
deep and easy to it you know I think
that the time has come and gone the the
crappy thing about stranger things is
it's like the the John Carter of Mars
paradox where people saw John Carter and
they were like this feels like Star Wars
and it's like well John Carter inspired
those things whereas people would go CET
to these with their little grubby hands
and a little young faces and they ripped
off stranger things and this is Dalton
like I hate you but night before
Christmas just do the same thing again
different and slightly better I thank
you Joestar sure sure okay
so in regards to ET to nocturnal fears I
feel like Julian made a really good
argument for net2 but not necessarily
specifically nocturnal fears which is
really like a nine-page horrible fanfic
that's just gone completely awry no one
wants to see Kitty torture porn that
sounds awful that it's mental mental and
physical torture of kids so we'll pass
on that one
as far as Nightmare Before Christmas - I
would say Jo when you say that it was
bigger for Tim Burton than Beetlejuice
or Edward Scissorhands that might have
been because the age that you were when
you saw it that Nightmare Before
Christmas being a children's film was
more on your radar than those other two
I would also say that the Nightmare
Before Christmas to that story is being
continued very well in comics right now
so I don't know that we need to see it
in a forced contrived plot with Jack
Skellington finding something new it's
like the sequel the sequel of Aladdin
I'll go back to that is like jasmine and
Aladdin getting married I mean every
every hero has one big story that their
life centers around and we just feel
like we've seen Jack's anything we see
after that is going to be secondary to
his first is our final thoughts
it's not true and then to drive it home
at the mountains of madness for when
Julia said that Deadpool could not be
used because it's not a horror my point
about Deadpool was showing that an
r-rated movie can be a commercial
success can make a studio money and that
it did and as far as Lovecraft movies
not being made because there's something
about them that needs to stay deep we
have seen with the onslaught of Dungeons
and Dragons entertainment and popularity
that's out there right now vampire the
masquerade werewolf all of all of these
tabletop games that have just come into
the forefront for everyone even though
some people the minority have been
playing them for decades now now they
are popular now's the time strike that
audience they're hungry for more
look at those Arkham Horror board games
that are so popular right now that
people just love and El Toro would be
the perfect director to do this not only
because of his passion for this specific
project but also because he's been
working on it for so long it's so well
thought out it's not gonna be a
money-grubber off of a franchise that's
already around and they're just hoping
to reclaim that audience from the
original this is a brand new movie that
people haven't seen before and it needs
to be made he's hot off the shape of
water come on Studios let's do it all
right time that is our round boom Dan
Merle take us to the fact zone Disney
does still own the rights to the
Nightmare Before Christmas they
reportedly proposed a sequel in 2001
with computer animation that Tim Burton
convinced them to drop nocturnal fears
was a nine-page treatment from Melissa
Mathison who wrote et it did future
scenes with Gertie crying for help while
the children are being interrogated and
were examined by aliens with razor-sharp
teeth but et would come in at the end
and rescue them and the momma Mia to
soundtrack is not all reused music I
it's about 1/3 we use another 2/3 of use
new songs so I look at the world third
full so that's how I do it
Thank You Julia and thank you Dan for
those facts so we had some some strong
arguments here and all interesting
ventures but when when when it came when
it came down to it the person who had
the most vivid picture who really
incorporated the directors filmography
and brought the passion at the end of
the day and it was Trisha for me and
she'll said some good some good dings on
the other competitors Joe again I
thought you I love Jack Skellington but
I did Hans how yeah I love them I love
them keeping time to do and Julia yeah
you you painted an interesting picture
of this the et2 and taking me back to
the ride and incorporating stranger
things but yeah Trisha got it for me so
it's one for Trish Dan yeah I challenged
Joe was doing well for me but then he
closed its closing I'm just like just do
the same thing again but you know
different it was like well that doesn't
sound very appealing and also when Joe
was like what do you want another event
horizon like kind of that kind and so I
thought Trisha tight-end why it should
have been made why it would work in
today's current climate the the demand
for it is there he's in a different
place in his career he's hot off the
shape of water I just thought it all
came together for me so I also agree
with Trisha and at the Mountains of
Madness bam Trisha could you do me a
favor and snap your finger with the
Infinity Gauntlet all right half of us
gonna disappear we'll find out
still here Oh Danielle what here
Internet have to say all right so for
the poll
it was 52% at the mountain of madness
35% for Nightmare Before Christmas to be
fierce with 11%
going over to Twitter has 17 said the
Fatty Arbuckle picture with Farley or
candy or Belushi
that sounds great and I can think of
many reasons why that is never going to
happen but I did it's done really good
all of you should be over the movie
fights last hashtag to see some of the
answers from this one this one was where
people really got into it there's too
many good ones to read also I have to
shout this out because it's made me the
happiest person in the entire world
yes someone sent us a meme that they did
cloudy J it's pause
so it's jaws but with a corgi at the
bottom with the shark bit yeah hey dude
next time add an owl in there you know
what I'm saying
pause that's true they have talents yeah
Danielle thank you so much and yeah I
just thought um the confederate
confederacy of dunces is one of my
favorite book that i heard about being
made several times but they've never
gotten around to it make that please
okay great
so we're heading to the speed round it's
tricia with two joe with one julia you
valiant effort very honey a lot of cool
stuff i went in god parking validation
great julia awesome having you it's been
awesome being here funny stuff
deteriorating ratings of the polls but
it's okay
okay I might come to you for for an
opinion it's like a $30.00 max and
parking so you're fine in a speed round
time no so the way the speed round works
again I will ask the question shout out
your answers first person to answer will
be able to elaborate on their answer
first and they'll get 20 seconds their
opponent will get 20 seconds and then
rebuttals 10 seconds 10 seconds players
ready for this will be chiming in with
her own opinion now no time for the
polls and speed round you are a person
and then some thank you
here we go question number 1 speed round
bad boys 3 is confirmed what actor
should join the bad boys series as a
third bad boy or girl
Bradley Cooper Millie Bobby Brown
Bradley Cooper stranger things 11
million all right Trish you I heard you
first 20 seconds begin whenever you
speak not only is bradley cooper superba
loveable and super liked by audiences
right now he can do that evil streak
we've seen him do it and we've seen him
be incredibly funny time and again and I
think that he would really just nail the
comedy that's in the bad boys films he'd
do it amazingly and he'd be an excellent
addition to that cast something that we
haven't seen yet in those films Joestar
I don't think you need a wacky third for
Martin Lawrence and Will Smith at some
point you need sort of a straight person
to bounce them off of and Milly Bobby
Brown is a weird and fun and solid
choice for those big personalities
you could change up the formula after
all the action and destruction now they
just have to like talk to local kids
about crime and the importance of police
and this is a girl that sort of lobs on
to them because she's like a fan of cops
or whatever and gets sucked into the
action do we won't really want to bring
kids into into this kind of movie I feel
like you're just asking for things that
are gonna be triggers all over the place
for today's audience right now with the
culture and the climate that we're in if
Milly Bobby Brown confided Emma Corden
she can pistol whip a guy with a
revolver and then have a snarky quit
with Will Smith I think it's a really
interesting choice in a weird casting
decision a really fun one Bradley Cooper
we've seen them all right Danielle
Radford give us your thoughts and
feelings both great arguments I do have
to say unfortunately because the church
was getting somewhere really good and
she wound up getting cut off
jozu argument wound up being more well
rounded just because you managed to talk
faster and get more words in there so
I'm also the the pistol-whipped one made
me laugh a little John
yeah I thought they were two interesting
choices but I gots to agree with
Danielle I thought Joe had the the
stronger argument and I thought he
parried well with what when Trish tried
to knock him down in the rebuttal so I
am going Joe star this is all tied up
Julia who do you have any thoughts on
that one I liked Joe's answer as well I
wrote down kick-ass is being a really
great example of when children fight
crime and connect story but I also think
that there's um you know the small
scrappy child trying to be a part of a
group is something that we haven't seen
in a while like truly the last example I
can think of is West Side Story with the
sharks and that one girl that was like
come on I want to play too I wanted to
be that child how can we watch that
thanks Julia okay we're all locked up at
2-2 here we go number two deuces wild
two - question over to the speed round a
gladiator sequel is in the works
who could forget Maximus fighting Tigers
in the first gladiator right so what
animal should the hero have to take on
in the Coliseum in the sequel a bear
okay a bear Joe star a komodo dragon
okay we have the bear versus the dreaded
Komodo dragon 20 seconds begin whenever
you speak Trisha I think a man fighting
a bear is something we've seen in
literature we've seen it in video games
we've seen it in lots of different media
as like the ultimate test of 10 you
survive and in Gladiator that's what
it's about it's about man at his primal
can he do it just his own self
are you there and fighting a bear would
do that bears are terrified you seen the
Reming you seen a man fight a bear
you've never seen a gladiator fight a
komodo dragon Komodo dragons are
terrifying they're faster that's the
closest thing you're gonna get to
fighting a dinosaur in ancient Rome and
that sounds crazy that sounds so fun
they've got their they've got poison and
their teeth they're really just mess you
up you kid there's no way to like plan
for a komodo dragon
I feel like gladiator needs to be based
in some sort of reality to be relevant
and if he was actually fighting a komodo
dragon I don't think there's any way
that our protagonist would survive he'd
be dead the Komodo dragon is terrifying
and it's the mostly but an amazing
twisted in the third act of your movie
your protagonist is killed by a komodo
dragon this one time there was a croc
hunter episode and he got to a pay with
the Komodo dragon you saw real fear in
his eyes oh boy oh boy
I want to see both of those fights y'all
Dan Merle which one did you want to see
much as weird as it would be to kill
your hero off in the third it's happened
before though like the Komodo dragon is
weren't wreaking to me I've got to be
honest I gotta say come on Oh dragon one
Okamoto Danielle hello Komodo
you know they were both really close but
I have to agree because I think that Joe
had that killer line about how we've
already seen I'm sorry
this is the time of the show and
Danielle loses it which always delights
me Thank You Danielle Joe star bolts
into it all right so this is a potential
game point Joe gets this he goes home a
winner
Trish needs us to tie it up John always
a winner in my book
no pressure all right here we go
question number three of the speed round
is 3/2 Joe star Mike Myers not the
Halloween killer is Saturday Night Live
slash Austin Powers Mike Myers says he's
still working on Austin Powers for still
working on it what time period would
make the better movie for Austin to go
back to the 50s or the 80s 80s
all right I'll argue the 50s you got 50s
by default Joe star came in first with
the 80s 20 seconds begin when you speak
now what happened in the 50s I don't
remember it was a weird time between the
Roaring Twenties and the hippy 60s v 40s
and 50s something happened I don't
remember it's a poorly defined time
whereas the 80s I know exactly what I'm
looking at I know Austin Powers is gonna
be in a Members Only jacket he's gonna
look at an AHA video and go take on me
baby
I know
there's just more to it there's more to
latch on to for an audience whereas the
50s it's like the 50s the 50s are sock
hops and poodle skirts and grease and
leather jackets and the t-birds and the
Pink Ladies I feel like that would be
the perfect world for the next Austin
Powers movie we could see Mike Myers do
some wonderful Elvis impersonations
we could see fat bastard drinking all
the soda at the soda shop all the ice
cream floats there's just such a fun
world for them to play in Austin was an
adult in the 60s which mean he grew up
in the 50s and the fun of Austin Powers
is made out of time not man revisits six
years ago in his teens 80 the 80s he's
ever been there so those are weird he's
like Reagan what's the deal baby
[Music]
the eighties were about to see with a
Wonder Woman film right now and I feel
like will it will have played in that
world already let's play somewhere
completely different with our next
Austin Powers film all right good
arguments y'all Danielle Radford yeah
these are both great arguments I want to
see both of those movies but Joe really
hit the crux of what makes an Austin
power movie work and that is man out of
time man who is experienced the time
he's never been to and so for that I got
to go with Jim all right that's one for
Joe Merle comma Dan the 50s what
happened couple things but that's
another show
you know this was this was a little
closer for me and I think Trisha was
able to pitch some more scenarios rather
than just like here's things that
existed in the eighties she was able to
put the characters into actual
situations in that time period which is
more appealing to me than just saying oh
whatever
Members Only and then that was those a
little bit and then the other thing
about it you know we've done the 80s a
lot we're about to do with one room and
that that ends me over a little bit so
it was very close but I actually go with
Trish Jones's all right so it's one one
for Joe and Trisha yeah
good grief it's so darn close I feel
like Joe had the better overall thesis
whereas Trisha yeah had the more
specifics and because I'm you know what
it's so close I gotta give it to Trish
and send it in to question number four
of the speed round all right here it is
this is for the game everybody Falcon
and Winter Soldier are getting their own
show on Disney streaming service what
MCU character should show up in the
pilot for a cameo Captain America
sorry what was the question again Falcon
and Winter Soldier are getting their own
show on the Disney streaming service
what MCU character should show up in the
pilot for a cameo
[Music]
kingpin all right is that doable is that
it's MCU Oh Marvel Cinematic Universe
it's all connected yeah there are like
newspaper headlines about the battle for
New York and the daredevil so there we
go yeah wow it okay so we heard Captain
America first Joe as kingpin Trisha 22nd
billion when you speak I think Captain
America is a fantastic role model for
kids we've seen the MCU poke fun at it
but I do really think that when we get
down to it if this is a show for kids
surrounding Falcon and Winter Soldier
the cap could bring a lot to the table
as far as educating kids as far as
teaching them nice moral lessons
especially in today's climate when
people are so heated about having
opinions it might be nice to have a
voice for truth and justice out there in
the show we have an outlet outlet for
that already it's the Captain America so
meme it's there it's done Vincent
D'Onofrio is kingpin is the greatest
villain in the MCU I've been waiting to
see him like he's a bigger threat to me
than Thanos see he's a bigger character
than Thanos and it'd be interesting to
see two guys that art has powered closer
to street-level that are in the Avengers
go up against a threat like kingpin and
also just Vincent D'Onofrio just yelling
his name that's my target kingpin is an
amazing character but I would love to
see him as more than just a cameo in the
first episode I would love to see him as
maybe the overarching season one or
something like that so and we know the
history that cap has with Winter Soldier
it'd be really nice to set up that
character I've already seen them
interact with Captain America a bunch
it's in the Captain America movies even
a brief interaction with Vincent knife
Rios kingpin would also just remind
everyone that these shows are all
actually connected which I feel like
people are really jaded about time yeah
that was real tough okay um I gotta go a
Joestar on this because yeah just seeing
them with a street-level character and
tying everything together
Pitney made it just a little bit more
vivid as to what kind of potential that
has Danielle um you know I have to agree
with you
going with Joestar on this one and for
one thing for mentioning how great
obviously King penny is the fact they
haven't interacted before and making
sure that we still have that connection
to the rest of the shows in the MCU
there you have it Joestar cakes had a
very strong argument but he backed off
of it when when Trisha brought up the
fact that was just a cameo so I actually
would it would have ended the same way
obviously but it would have had a little
drama there I appreciate that Giulio as
you think
I thought kingpin to write off Joestar
you take the day nicely thanks you're
stepping it at the last minute what a
pro what a gentleman Joe shout some
stuff out I'll shout out some things I'm
super pumped to have Trish you back on
the show it's been a super long time and
I'm really glad you're here again and
Julie is new to the channel but very
dear to me and a longtime friend make
sure you guys check out townies we're a
show called townies
it's the OC in the Old West you can
watch all of the first season on black
pills for free just watch it on your
phone if you want yeah very cool
John thank you so much thank you how
Trisha well play you took a Mac thank
you guys so much for having me it's good
to be back I feel like the last time I
was on movie fights it came down to Joe
and I in the speedrun and he kicked my
butt then too so Joe we will live to
fight another day
but well done especially being the
underdog in this fight having to argue
someone else's answers there great
answer off to you sir that was got a
part of kingpin in something
don't be amazing but seriously thank you
guys so much for having me it's been a
ton of fun to come and fight with
everybody well fought arguments today on
all sides guys
heck yeah thanks Trish where can they
find you you can find me on all the
social medias at that girl Trish with no
I in the girl or on YouTube or twitch at
Trisha Hershberger and I also host shows
for Newegg Kingston and geek and sundry
heck yeah
all the shows Thank You Julia Prescott
thank you so much for being here and I
remember one of my first instances of
knowing like whoa this woman loves
movies is when I saw you in that big
lebowski dress yeah I went to Lebowski
Fest every year for like six or seven
years and yeah when I ran into you I
forget what you were covering that event
for but I was for screen junkies and I
was drunk on white Russians
descent into drunk Julius
thank you so much always enjoy your
stuff please tell us where we can find a
get some shadows first I just want to
echo the sentiments of my co Patriots
today and this fight you guys have
really made me think to myself I really
got a you know up the bar for my own
research or maybe not maybe that's my
charm but yeah I host the podcast about
the Simpsons everything's coming up
Simpsons on maximum fun this just
twittered that I'm wearing my sister
Katie Prescott designed actually if you
google her I was like oh I should you
know promote my sister too
it's amazing you can find it on her shop
I believe on like T public or something
and then also I don't know buy my book
about the Simpsons yeah Julia Prescott
on all the things very cool thanks Julia
Dan Merle thank you for holding it down
as per usual
of course my pleasure always fun on the
Dan cam with my fellow Dan and yeah yeah
yeah shooting shooting off facts awesome
shoot and the voice of the people
Danielle Radford thank you thank you for
bringing the the the joy in the sunshine
and your laughter find me at Daniel
Radford on Twitter I have a patreon
where I talk about things did you say
patreon like skyward yes and I want to
thank you for watching
first of all thanks you too owl nation
thanks and big thanks to a jte Billy biz
I'm at Hal Rudnick on all the things and
don't forget everybody no matter what
your political affiliation go out and
vote on Tuesday November
we'll see you next time bye bye bye